cancel culture is real and it's
difficult and it's hard Candace Cameron
Beret gets real about the backlash over
her recent traditional marriage comments
you just have to scroll past it and get
over it doing a visit on the
Unapologetic with Julia Jeffrey Sadler
podcast the actress opens up about
online ridicule and maintaining your
truth it's important that we speak truth
but in love because listen Nobody's
Gonna Change nobody's gonna even listen
to you when it comes out angry when it
comes out in a harsh way but it's
important that we don't back down this
comes months after Candace said in an
interview that the Great American Family
a new Christian conservative Network she
joined will quote keep traditional
marriage at the core her controversial
remarks which some say invalidate
same-sex marriages prompted an outrage
on social media our words matter fast
forward to February during her chat on
the podcast Candace talked about these
struggles she says many Christians face
there's all places in the world all
different countries where people get
severely persecuted for their faith and
I feel like we've had this cushion here
in North America where you know someone
yells at us or someone just says a mean
negative thing and our feelings get so
hurt over it and that isn't merely the
persecution that a lot of other people
go through for being a Christian in
other countries I love having
conversations with
that is that's the I it's the best
because I want to hear how you feel
about it I want you to be able to listen
to how I feel about it but I want you to
say something that made me make me
change my mind in the wake of the
backlash Candace shared a lengthy
statement on social media saying quote I
am called to love all people and I do
adding I had also expressed in my
interview which was not included that
people of all ethnicities and identities
have and will continue to contribute to
the network in great ways both in front
of and behind the camera which I
encourage and fully support but despite
her clarification it's all led to a
public Rift between Candace and many
other celebs who've spoken out against
her including Jojo siwa I I can't handle
fake people who says Candace's remark
was rude and called it hurtful to a
whole community of people quote honestly
I can't believe after everything that
went down just a few months ago that she
would not only create a movie with
intention of excluding lgbtqia plus but
then also talk about it in the press and
Candace's former Full House co-star Jody
Sweetin offered support to Jojo writing
in the comments you know I love you it's
been quite a series of Life events that
we've all shared at the time A source
told E.T that the former on-screen
sisters had a pretty serious
disagreement partly because Jody is
Progressive in her beliefs while Candace
is religious in hers quote they have
different views and opinions on various
important topics it's hard no matter
what you know especially when you are a
compassionate person and you have a
heart for people
foreign
[Music]